Cool.
Hello, everyone, and welcome
to lecture 3 of CME 295.
So today is a very
exciting day, because we're
going to finally introduce
large language models.
But I guess before we
go into that I'm just
going to start, traditionally,
with some announcements.
So some of you wanted to have
the slides before the class.
So just a heads up
that in case you
want to use the slides
to do some annotations,
they're on the
website right now.
So feel free to get them.
And with Shervin, we'll try
to, just on a regular basis,
every Thursday evening, have
them publish on the website
so that you can download
them and annotate.
Cool.
So with that, let's start.
And as usual, we're going to
recap last week's episodes.
So if you remember,
lecture 1 and lecture 2
were all about introducing
the concept of self-attention
and linking them to the
construct of the transformer.
And what we did last lecture was
look at all the types of models
that are out there
and how they were all
based on the transformer.
So there are three categories,
three main categories of models.
So the first one that we saw
was encoder-decoder model,
which basically relies
on the transformer.
It has the encoder
of the transformer,
the decoder of the transformer.
And typically, the tasks
there are input text.
So text in, text out.
So we saw that one example
was T5 and all the variations.
The second type
of model is where
we remove the decoder
from the transformer
and we obtain an
encoder-only model.
So we went deeper
into BERT, which is
the typical encoder-only model.
And I guess, we
also saw that what
BERT has is this nice
property that it's encoded
embeddings are very meaningful
and expressive of the inputs.
And so we saw the example
of classification,
sentiment extraction.
So what we did
was, in particular,
take into consideration
the encoded embedding
of the CLS token.
So I guess in real life, BERT
is used to encode documents
to encode sentences.
And we're going to
see later in the class
how these models are useful.
And then last but
not least, we have
the third category of models,
which is decoder only.
So we only keep the decoder
part of the transformer.
And so here, we also do a
little bit of a modification.
So we remove the
cross-attention because we
don't need it anymore.
We don't have an encoder.
And these kinds of models
are text in, text out.
And so GPT is a very good
example of such models.
And actually, most models these
days, they're decoder-only.
So these are the
three main kinds
of models that you
can see out there.
So far so good for everyone?
Cool.
So with that, I'm going
to introduce the term LLM.
So LLM stands for
large language model.
So what is a large
language model?
So first of all, a
large language model
is a language model.
So a language model is a
model that assigns probability
to sequences of tokens.
So in this case,
our model always
predicts the probability
of the next token.
So it's, in that sense,
a language model.
But also, a large
language model is large.
So why is it large?
So we're going to see
that these models,
they are actually scaled
up in terms of size.
So first of all in
terms of model size.
So these days, it's not
uncommon to see models
on the order of hundreds
of billions of parameters.
But typically,
when we say LLM we
say at least on the
order of a billion.
These models, they've also been
trained on a huge amount of data
and hereby amount of
data, we quantify that
by the number of tokens that
they were pre-trained with.
And this is on the
order of magnitude
of hundreds of
billions of tokens
or even trillions of tokens.
So I think the biggest ones are
like on the tens of trillions
of tokens.
So huge training sets.
And they're also large because
they need a lot of compute.
So typically you need a bunch
of GPUs to make them work.
Although these days there's
been a lot of optimizations
to have them work on
consumer based GPUs.
So we're going to
see that later on.
But in LLM is large according
to these categories.
So another thing that
I want to point out
is that all these terminologies,
they're relatively new.
So I remember in
2018, '19, there was
no real definition of an LLM.
I think no one actually
talked about LLMs.
In the beginning, maybe
people talked about LLMs.
They included BERT.
But Bert is an
encoder-only model
that does not produce text.
So with the current
definition of an LLM,
which right now has been
pretty well established,
BERT would not be an LLM
because it doesn't produce text.
So here, we only
consider language models
that do text to text, that are
very large in size, in terms
of amount of data that have
been trained on and in terms
of compute.
Cool.
And as we saw before, these
models are decoder-only.
So here, what we do is
we remove the encoder,
we only keep the
masked self-attention,
the feedforward neural
network, and then the addition
and normalization.
So we only keep this.
And this is the
backbone of LLMs.
And so I mentioned GPT is
kind of a good example.
But it's not just that.
You have plenty of other models.
So you may have heard of
LLaMA from Meta, Gemma
from Google, DeepSeek,
Mistral, Qwen, and so on.
The list is long.
I would say roughly--
I mean, more than 90%
of modern day LLMs,
they're all decoder-only.
So I think that's
something to keep in mind.
Cool.
OK.
So now you how LLMs are made of.
But there is something else
that people these days also
introduce to these models.
And we're going to
see that in a bit.
So I mentioned that
these models are
huge in size, again,
typically hundreds of billions
of parameters.
So it takes a lot of compute
to just compute one inference,
or also to train these models.
But you may wonder,
do you really
need to have all
these parameters be
activated during a forward pass,
to make a simple prediction?
So I'm going to have
a little metaphor.
So let's suppose
you enter in a room.
And in the room, there is a
mathematician, a physicist,
a chemist and a historian.
So you come in
this class, there's
a bunch of people who are
expert in what they do.
And you have a question,
you have a math question.
So a question I have for you is,
who would you ask your question?
Would you ask the mathematician?
Would you ask the chemist?
Would you ask everyone?
Well, right now,
we ask everyone.
We ask all parameters
of the model
to be involved in the
computation of the generation.
And so the idea here
is given an input,
maybe it's not necessary
to ask everyone
to be involved in
the computation.
So the idea is let's actually
just have a subset of the model
be involved in the
computation of the next token.
So I'm just introducing
this idea of experts.
So let's suppose
we're introducing
the following notation.
So let's suppose
we have n experts.
So think of it as your
mathematician, your chemist,
historian, whatever.
So these are your experts.
And the idea is given an input
x, you're going to ask yourself
who should be involved in the
generation of the outputs.
So you're going to have,
let's say, another network.
Where we're going to
call it G like gates,
but it's also sometimes
called router.
So let's suppose we have
some gates that tells us
which experts should be
involved in the inference.
So if we have that,
so let's suppose here,
the gate tells us OK, so
actually, expert number 2
is well suited to
answer your question.
So here, the idea is
that the input is just
going to flow into that expert,
but not the other experts.
So this has a name.
It's called mixture of experts.
So it's denoted MoE.
Everyone talks about MoE.
So these are a
mixture of experts.
And so the formula that you
will see a lot is this one.
So the output y,
which is denoted y hat
is the sum of the expert output
weighted by some quantity, which
is the output of the
gate, which tells you
how important the output
of each expert is.
Yeah.
Great question.
So the question is,
how do you train G?
How do you train
E. So typically,
you train them jointly.
So we're going to see that
maybe in a little later.
But you can think of it
as just training as usual.
You do your forward pass,
you compute the loss
and you backprop.
And it's actually an
interesting question
because there is some challenges
that come with training MoEs
that we're going
to see in a second.
Yeah.
Question is, what are these E's.
What is the architecture
of these E's?
So let's suppose right now
that there's just some network.
We're not specifying
them for now,
but we're going to
see this in a second.
Let's suppose for now,
it's some network.
Cool.
OK.
So I told you that what if
we don't activate everyone.
What if we activate a subset?
But this formula,
actually, I guess,
assumes that we're actually
considering all expert outputs.
So I just want to distinguish
two kinds of MoEs.
So there's one kind that
is called a dense MoE.
So a dense MoE
actually does not have
any constraints on the number
of experts that are involved.
So these weights, they can
be anywhere between 0 and 1.
So think of them as a
probability distribution.
But it's just going to put more
weight towards some experts
compared to others.
So back to the example that
I had, so let's suppose
I have a math question.
So I'm going to ask
the mathematician,
the chemist, the historian.
So I'm probably going
to add a higher weight
to what the mathematician
says compared
to let's say, the historian.
So this is the idea.
But then the
interesting thing is
when we constrain
the number of experts
that are activated,
because here,
as we mentioned
previously, what we're
interested in is to
not involve everyone
is to make some savings in the
amount of compute that we do.
So there's a second kind of MoE
that's called the sparse MoE.
And what it does is it only
selects the quote unquote,
"top k" experts.
So k can be equal to 1.
So one expert or even two.
So it's a hyperparameter
that you choose.
And so here, the
expression of the output
becomes the sum over
all the chosen experts
of a G of x times E of x.
So far, so good?
Cool.
And of course, there's
a lot more to it.
So in case you are
interested in learning more,
feel free to go into
the resources that
are at the bottom of the slide.
So one thing that I
will say is that we
have a unit of measure
of the amount of compute
that these models
produce for each pass.
So you will see the term FLOPS.
So have you seen the
term FLOPS out there?
No, not really.
So it stands for
floating-point operations.
So it quantifies
how many operations.
Think of it as additions,
multiplications
are involved in a
forward pass let's say.
And it basically quantifies
how compute heavy is your task.
So typically, what
we say is when
we go through a sparse MoE
as opposed to a dense Moe,
we have a lower amount of FLOPS.
So this is the unit of
measure that you will see.
But back to your question,
so what are these experts?
So if you remember, I mean, 10
minutes ago, we said that LLMs,
they are decoder-only models.
So I have a question for you.
Let's suppose we wanted to
put some MoEs in our LLM.
Where would we put it?
So here, I guess, we
have three choices.
We have the masked
self-attention layer.
We have the feedforward
neural network.
And then we have
this normalization.
So question for you, I guess,
where would you put this?
I guess, where do you think is--
I guess, the most complex
parts of the network.
Where is there a
lot of operations?
Feedforward?
Yes.
Yeah.
Great answer.
So it's indeed the
feedforward neural network.
And the reason for that is I
think Shervin mentioned it,
I think, in lecture 1.
So if you remember, the
feedforward neural network
is a network such that
you have the input, which
is your D-dimensional
input vector.
And then you have this being
projected into, let's say,
a DFF dimensional space.
And then it goes back to the
D-dimensional, I guess, space.
So the DFF is typically larger
than your dimension of, I guess,
the inputs.
When I say input, it's here.
So it's typically larger.
So the amount of
parameters that you
have in that feedforward
neural network
is something on the order of
magnitude of D model times
DFF times 2 plus some bias.
So it's basically your
order of magnitude.
And the attention
layer, if you remember,
it's basically composed of
the projection matrices,
what is the dimension of
the projection matrices.
So it's D model
times the dimension
of keys to dimension of queries
the dimension of values.
And this dimension is
typically much lower.
So think of it over 100.
So your D model is typically
O over 100, O over 1,000.
And then the projection here,
the DFF is O over 1,000,
O over 10,000.
Cool.
So is everyone now
convinced that this
is a good way, good place to
put the mixture of experts?
Yeah?
Cool.
So this is actually
how it's done.
So in modern day LLMs, this
idea of not involving everyone
in the computation of
the next token prediction
is such that you would
put the mixture of experts
where the fn is
just basically here.
And typically you would have
a sparse mixture of experts.
So back to your question,
so these experts
are actually feedforward
neural network.
So you would have several
networks that you can train,
but you would only activate one.
So typically, k
would be equal to 1.
It can be also equal to 2 but
it would only be a subset.
So that's my point.
And this routing would be
done at the token level.
So if you remember, the
decoder, it basically
takes something as inputs.
So a bunch of tokens.
And here, what I'm
saying is that each token
will be processed by
an expert that may be
different from the other token.
So the router here would take
the representation of the token
as input and figure out
which expert should be best
for this token to flow towards.
Does this idea make sense?
So I have a little
illustration later
on that hopefully will help.
So now back to your question
about how you train this model.
Do you train the
router separately?
experts separately?
So one challenge
that people have
is when they train these
MoE-based models, to make sure
that all experts are, I guess,
having a weight, are being used.
Because it's very possible
that you train your model
and that somehow
only, I don't know,
one or two experts
always get activated.
And the other one, they
always are inactive.
They are never involved
in the computation.
So this problem is
called routing collapse.
So why is it called
routing collapse?
It's because the
router always chooses
some experts, but not others.
So this is a challenge.
And the way people
try to mitigate
this challenge is by
changing the loss function
and adding it some extra
term, which is written here.
So it's basically some
hyperparameter alpha times
the number of experts
times the sum of quantities
that depend on
whether or not tokens
went to a certain expert's
eye, and then summed
over all experts.
So it's not super important
that you completely understand
exactly how that formula works.
The only thing that I think you
should take away from this slide
is that this extra loss allows
these quantities to converge
more towards uniform
distributions.
So what are these quantities,
just as a reminder.
So f of I is the
fraction of tokens
that are routed to
expert I. And P of I
is the average routing
probability for expert I.
So when I say that all experts
should be used the same, what
I'm saying is I want
this probability to be
kind of uniform across experts.
Yeah.
So the question
is, I guess, when
do you compute these quantities?
So yeah, you can think of it
as a regular training process.
You do some mini batch,
you go through the model
and then you compute
all these quantities.
And then what you do is
you do your backpropagation
based on that.
And I guess what I
want you to remember
is that this incentivizes
the probability,
I guess, the choice
of the writer
to be more uniform
across experts,
which is something that
mitigates this routing collapse
phenomenon.
Yeah.
So the question is,
can we use Dropout?
Of course.
You can always bundle that
with some other techniques.
So people have just kind of
found this to be very helpful.
So speaking of other
techniques, there
is something that
I've not talked about,
which is very similar
to the Dropout idea.
So it's called noisy gating.
Noisy gating is basically
you have your predictions
from the gates, but then
you add some noise to it.
So basically, it's
by pure chance,
it just allows other experts to
be involved in the computation.
So it's also some
other technique.
There's a bunch of techniques.
But yeah, Dropout is indeed
quite useful for things
like overfitting.
And the idea can be reused
in different settings.
Yep.
So the question
is, how can you--
so do you mean differentiable?
So here, I guess, how do
you take the derivative.
Is that your question?
How is the derivative--
can you explain a bit more
what your concern is?
So I guess, to this question, so
the average routing probability.
So that one is a function
of the gate output.
That's one.
PI.
So I guess, your
question is for FI.
For FI, OK.
I don't have a good
answer on top of my head,
but I think people
have some techniques.
And these days, you just don't
even have to do this by hand.
You have the built in thing.
So maybe I can follow
up with you for FI.
But for P of I, do you see
that this one is quite clean.
It's just the average of the
probabilities from the gates.
Yeah.
So basically the probability--
the output probability
from the gate,
you can think of it as just
the vector being projected
on a space of n,
where n corresponds
to your number of experts.
And then it's gone
through Softmax.
So your output is basically
summing up to one.
And each of these
dimensions, they
represent the
value corresponding
to what expert I would
be, I guess, used for.
For instance, the first
dimension would be for expert 1,
second dimension would be
for expert 2, and so on.
So you just take the average
of this, and this one,
you can express it from
all the parameters.
So I think you should
be fine with that one.
Yeah.
So the question is if we
increase the number of MoEs,
does it increase the
number of model parameters?
So it's a great question.
So it's actually one of the
ideas behind MoE-based models,
which is that you can scale
the model without having
to incur the cost of having
significantly more compute
at inference time.
So you can increase--
so people say capacity.
Can increase the
capacity of your model,
but you will still keep some,
I guess, like controlled amount
of active parameters.
And active parameters
are the parameters that
are used for a forward pass.
So yeah, people just use that.
So yeah, it would just increase
the number of parameters.
So that's why you see
some MoE-based models that
are even bigger than
the ones that we
had on the order of
hundreds of billions.
We even have on the order
of trillions of parameters.
So for instance here,
one reading I recommend
is switch transformer,
which scaled up to one point
something trillion parameters.
So yeah, it's definitely more.
But that being said, so
if you read the paper,
you will also see that
these models, there
are more what they
call sample efficient.
So they take less time
to be as good as what
the model would have been with
a lower number of parameters.
So if you draw
the training curve
as a function of
the training time,
you see that these models are
typically more sample efficient.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Everything here is a trade off.
Yeah.
Cool.
So the question is,
each attention head
will have a number of experts.
So it's actually regardless
of the attention heads.
So the attention heads,
you can think of them
as being independent,
something else.
And the number of experts
is independent of that.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Right.
All right.
Yeah.
The question is whether every
block will have a number.
The answer is yes.
And typically those
weights are not shared.
So typically, you-- so actually,
we're going to see an example.
It can very well
be that layer 1,
there is the expert
number at all.
Three that was chosen, but layer
2, there is expert number 1,
and, you know, it's all free.
It's trainable.
So the question
is we will decide
where the expert will go to.
So all of that is decided by the
gates, which is this quantity.
Everything is
decided by the gates,
which has trainable weights.
So you can think of this as just
some projection from the input
x to an n dimensional
space, where
n is the number of experts.
So the question is, at what
point during the inference
is it decided?
So let's suppose we're
at inference time.
I'm going to walk you
through how it works.
So you have your x.
So you have this
attention mechanism.
So it interacts with all
tokens from the past given that
its decoder-only.
So it's like the mask.
It goes here.
And at the beginning of the
feedforward neural network
block, the token is,
of course, contextual.
So it has the information
from these other tokens
because it's attended.
And what it does
is it goes here.
So x first goes into G. G
computes this probability
distribution over all experts.
And given here that we are
in a sparse MoE setting,
we will only choose the top k.
So let's suppose the top one,
just the highest probability.
And we know which
experts this one will be.
And so as a result of
that, you will only
compute the output
value of the expert
that the input was chosen.
So can you elaborate
on that actually?
Yeah.
At what point exactly?
So it's after the
self-attention layer.
Yeah.
So the question is, do we
have different classification
for different heads?
No.
So there's only one router.
So I think I understand
your question.
So your question
is, what do you do
given that you have different
attention computations going on
in parallel with the heads?
So if you remember,
the attention layer
has these different heads.
But at the end of
it, what it does
is it concatenates all the
results from each of these heads
and then projects it once
again in the D model space.
Yeah.
So the question is, do
we have different Gs?
So the only thing I can tell
you is that the G is just
layer specific.
It's layer specific.
It's trainable.
So it's basically going to learn
how to process all these inputs.
So the G, the only thing I
can tell you for your question
is going to be layer specific.
So the G is going to
be one G for let's say
the first layer, another G for
the second layer, and so on.
And that one is
going to be trained.
Cool.
Great.
Looking at the time.
Do we have any other
questions here?
We're good.
Perfect.
So now I just wanted to
show you a cool thing
that I believe the
Mistral team was
showing in one of their papers.
So what they're showing here
was for a given piece of text,
to show in which experts
each token was rooted.
So as we noted
before, so experts
are different from
one layer to another.
So I believe here,
for layer 0, so it's
like for one given layer.
And we do see that
roughly, these tokens,
I guess, they leverage
like a uniform amount
of experts, more or less.
What you would
not want to see is
to have every token
be the same color.
But luckily it is not.
But yeah, so that's one cool
way of just representing
how the routing is done is
to just have your input text
and just represent where
each token-- in which experts
each token went.
Cool.
OK.
So what we just saw was one way
that modern day LLMs changed
their architecture to
incorporate the fact that we may
want to scale the model, but
not increase the computation
complexity for one forward pass.
And we saw that with MoEs.
So you will see a lot of
MoE-based LLMs out there.
And now what we will do is
knowing that we have an LLM,
we're going to focus on--
don't worry.
We're going to focus on how a
response is being generated.
So remember, when I told you
that these modern day LLMs, what
they do is they take some text
in and they have some text out.
So it's typically these task
of next token prediction.
So you have a token in.
So let's say,
beginning of sentence,
you go through your
LLM and it just
generates the next
word or the next token.
So A, and then you take A,
and then it goes to teddy.
And then teddy bear is,
et cetera, et cetera.
But so far, we have
never really dug
into exactly how we
chose the next token.
So what we're going
to do right now
is to see exactly how we're
generating the next token.
So as you know,
here, our LLM is just
a decoder-only architecture.
So here, what you have is a
decoder with your inputs here,
and then your output there.
So let's suppose for a
second that everything that's
happening in the middle.
And we're just obtaining
output probabilities
that are going to look
a little bit like this.
So given a token or some
sequence of tokens as inputs,
you have an output
probability distribution
that represents what the
model thinks is the likelihood
that there will be a
next token, let's say,
that is equal to A, to
airplane, to fluffy, et cetera.
So this is what you have.
So now my question to
you is, if we told you
we have some sequence
as inputs and we want
to choose the next token, and
if I told you that our model is
giving out actually a
probability distribution,
I guess, how would you choose
the next token based on this?
Sorry.
Great.
The token with
maximum probability.
OK, great.
So yes, the first idea.
Let's just take the token
with highest probability.
So it's a very natural approach.
But I'm not sure if
you've been using things
like ChatGPT or Gemini.
Every time you ask
something, it always
responds something that
is slightly different.
So if you always
choose the token
with the highest probability,
given that the computation here,
we're going to see
is all deterministic.
What that means is
you're always going
to generate the same
thing regardless of,
I guess, with the same input.
So that's one limitation.
So it's not very diverse.
The second problem is if you
choose the highest probability
token on, I guess, iterative
basis, your locally optimal,
but you're not necessarily
globally optimal.
So what does that mean?
So I guess, if you
think about it,
our objective is for us to
produce a sequence, an output
sequence of tokens that is, I
guess, of a high probability.
But the problem is, if you
always choose the highest
probability token, you will not
necessarily obtain the highest
probability sequence.
Are you convinced of this
statement, by the way?
So let me give you an example.
So let's suppose you have the
next token where one token is
0.8, the other one is 0.7.
And then you choose
to go with the 0.8.
No, actually, it's not 0.7
because it has to sum to 1.
So let's say 0.2.
So let's suppose if you go
ahead with the sequence that
starts with the
0.8, let's suppose
all other token
probabilities are very low.
Basically, you will
have an output sequence
that will have a lower
probability than let's
say, the other path, which
would, let's suppose,
have higher probability
predictions in the later steps.
So we're going to
see this in a second.
But this is the idea.
So if you choose the highest
predicted probability,
it's a good first idea.
But it's locally optimal,
but not necessarily globally
optimal.
And this is the
reason why we have
a second method that
is about keeping track
of the k most probable path.
So I'm not sure if you've
heard of beam search.
So that's what beam search does.
So here, k, is sometimes called
the beam size or the beam width.
So if you hear
these terms, these
are just names that are
given to the number of paths
that we keep track of.
And so this works as follows.
So let's suppose we start our
generation with the beginning
of sentence token.
We want to figure out
what the next token is.
So let's suppose we have here,
in this example, a very basic
example like three tokens.
And let's suppose the two
highest probable tokens
are A and the.
So if we have k equal to
2, what we're going to do
is to keep track of
these two branches.
So that's the first iteration.
The second iteration
is we're going
to look at all the probabilities
of next token prediction
for these two tokens.
And we're going to always save
the two most probable paths.
And here, for
instance, let's suppose
if it's like the, and then
fluffy and then A and cute.
So back to what I
was saying earlier,
so what I was saying was
here, if you were choosing
the path that went along
the highest probability
token path, like the the,
it's very much possible
that the highest
probability token
after there would be a
much lower probability
than the one after A.
And so this is what
beam search tries to do.
It tries to have a more
globally optimal solution.
So let's suppose
we continue that.
And then at the end of the
day, we obtain, I guess,
a number of potential, I
guess, choices and the k
potential choices.
And then we pick the one
that is the highest, likely,
the sequence with the
highest probability.
So people typically
what they do is
they take the sum of the
logarithm of the probabilities
of the tokens.
So what they say
is they say, OK.
So the log probability
of the sequence
is the sum of the
log probability
of each next token prediction.
So it's the log probability of
A, knowing BOS, and then cute,
knowing BOS and A, and
so on and so forth.
But I just want to point out
one limitation of this approach,
which is that the more you
generate tokens, the lower your,
I guess, end sequence
probability will be.
Because if you think about
it, all these probabilities
are between 0 and 1.
So think of it like in
the multiplied sense.
So let's suppose you
have the probability
of the whole sequence,
which is just
a multiplication of the
probability of the next token.
The more you add probabilities
below, like less than 1,
the more this quantity
will go towards 0.
So I guess this method,
as is, will prioritize
sequences that are shorter.
And so for that
reason, beam search
has some additional
term that basically
counteracts that effects.
So something on the order
of 1 over number of tokens
to the power of something.
So in practice, there
is some technique
to make sure that things
kind of work relatively well.
OK.
Let's suppose we figure
out all these things.
The problem is that
we need to keep track
of this most probable path.
We need to do all this
kind of saving, et cetera.
And it requires a
lot of computation.
And the other thing
is we're still
interested in the most probable
path, which basically will lead
to a sequence that is very--
that the model thinks
is very likely.
But sometimes what you
want is for your output
to be more diverse
or more creative.
So that's why beam search
is actually not something
that people typically use.
People use beam
search for things
like machine translation,
where you actually
need to have something
that is close to something
being very likely.
But actually, people
use a third method.
And this method is called
also the sampling method.
So I told you we
have a probability
distribution over
tokens regarding
what the next token should be.
And so what people
do is they just
sample the next token using
that probability distribution.
Does this make sense?
So in this example, fluffy,
gentle, kind, and let's say
smart will have a higher
probability of being drawn
as opposed to let's say
airplane, that have a lower
probability of occurring.
Non-zero probability, but they
have a probability of occurring.
Cool?
Any questions so far?
Yeah.
Right.
So the question is it's not for
training, it's for inference.
Yes, correct.
Think of it as a
response generation.
So let's suppose you have
your model that is trained.
What you want is to
generate an output.
So what would you do?
Yeah.
So I guess, just to complete
my answer, so during training,
what you would do is care
about the output probabilities
and then compare them with
the actual label, which
is, most of the time,
like your hard label.
And yeah, this is what
you would compare.
So this one is let's suppose
you have an LLM that is trained,
how would you
generate a response?
Cool.
Are on goods?
Yeah.
So the question is, how do you
do sampling in this situation.
So it's actually my next slides.
But I just want to
make sure everyone
was on the same page
regarding just the intuition.
So highest probability is
called greedy decoding.
It's probably not
something that we want.
Beam search is a
little bit better.
It's more something that
is globally optimal.
It's not globally optimal
but more towards that.
So it's better but
it lacks diversity.
It lacks creativity.
Which is why what
we want to do is
to actually sample each token.
And I guess, we
have a few methods
that also restrict
the kinds of tokens
that we want to sample from.
Because I mentioned, these
very low probability tokens,
they can still,
theoretically, be sampled.
But it's not necessarily
something that we want.
So what people do is
they typically restrict
the highest probability tokens
and only sample from them.
So you may have heard of
this term, Top-k sampling.
Who has heard of this term?
Yeah, a little bit.
So what you do is you select
the top highest probable k--
so the top k highest probable
tokens and you sample from them.
So let's suppose
if k is equal to 4,
you take the four
highest probable.
And then you just
sample with them.
And there's something else
that is quite similar in idea
which is called Top-p.
So Top-p is that
you limit yourself
to the top to the highest
probable tokens such
that their cumulative
probability is
more than a threshold p.
So again, it will
do the same thing.
It will select the
highest probable tokens.
But then there is a part
that I still left out,
which is how do you obtain these
probabilities to start with?
So if you remember, here, I had
mentioned that we just assume
we have the probabilities.
We just have them and we want to
choose what the next token is.
But now the question
that I'm asking
is now that we know what we will
do with these probabilities,
I guess, one question
is, how do you
obtain these probabilities
to start with.
So if you remember, these
transformer-based architecture
basically computes an encoder
representation of the input.
And what you have
is some final layers
at the very top of
the figure, which
aims at projecting the
vector into the space
of the vocabulary.
Because what you want to
do is to have a probability
number for how probable it is
for you to sample a given token.
So here, what you would
do is at the very top
of the architecture,
have your input,
which is your encoded
embedding of the token.
Go through a linear layer, which
basically projects your D model
vector into a space of
dimension size of v.
And of course, what you
want is probabilities.
So you would have
a Softmax layer,
which basically converts
everything to probabilities
such that everything sums to 1.
And in order to compute
the probabilities,
this is the formula
that you would use,
which is the Softmax layer.
So there is a
hyperparameter that
is quite important that I
want to talk to you about,
which is the temperature T. And
so this is where it pops up.
So you have the probability of
the next token being a given
word, which is equal
to the exponential
of the input with respect to
the given word over temperature.
And then you normalize
that by the sum
of all the other exponential
of the quantity over t.
And now what we're going to
see is what that T is used for
or what that T actually
does in practice.
So before we go into
that, just one question.
Has anyone heard about
temperatures when it
comes to response generation?
Yeah.
Cool.
So hopefully that will
give you a better idea
of how the temperature
kind of influences
your output predictions.
So I guess, the
question that I want
to ask you is, what would
be the impact of having
a low temperature versus
a high temperature?
So low temperature would
correspond to a diverse of what?
Yeah.
So we will come to
that in a second.
So yeah, do you have a--
a lower temperature?
Increase in temperature.
So I guess, back to
the explanation about,
I guess, lowering
the temperature
and what impact it
will do to the--
so I guess do you have a
suggested response to that?
I guess, lower temperature.
Let's suppose you have a lower
temperature, what happens?
Yeah.
So I guess-- so the
long story short
is low temperature will
create a spiky distribution
and then high temperature will
create a uniform distribution.
But I guess, I think you
had the right intuition.
I'm going to maybe write this
in more mathematical terms.
OK.
Let's suppose you have
your probability, which
is the exponential of xi over
t, over the sum of exponential
of xj over t.
So just mathematically,
you can actually
prove what is happening here.
So let's suppose you have
the index of the highest xi.
So let's call that k.
So let's suppose what I do is
I will factor by this quantity.
So actually, here,
I don't have space.
So let's do here.
So it will be ae
of k temperature.
And then here, you have the sum
of over all j of exponential
of xj over t minus xk over t.
So what I did is
I just multiplied
the numerator and
the denominator
by exponential of xk over t.
So I multiplied numerator
and denominator.
And of course, they cancel out.
But then what I have here
is xy minus xk over t.
And here, xj minus k over t.
So when i is equal
to k, this term is 0.
It's exactly 0, regardless
of the temperature.
And here, xj minus xk
is always negative or 0.
So here, if i is equal
to k, you have 0 over t.
So here, it's 1.
And then you have 1 plus--
I guess, some quantity.
So j minus xk over t, which
is going to be negative.
So the t going to 0.
So that one will be,
I guess, going to,
let's say, minus infinity.
So exponential of
minus infinity is 0.
So what you will end
up with is something
where for i equal to k, you will
have a non-zero probability.
But then for i not
equal to k, you
will have 0 over something that
is not equal to 0, which is 0.
So just mathematically, if you
factor by exponential of xk
over t, where k is the
index of the highest value,
I guess, the highest logit or
the highest activation vector,
can actually show that for
a small temperature, only
the highest--
so the index of the,
I guess, highest value
will be the one that will be
highest probable with the spike
there.
And then when you have
a high temperature,
basically it will look
like a uniform distribution
because all these quantities, so
when t tends to plus infinity,
this tends to 0.
So exponential of 0 is just e.
Sorry, not e, 1.
So 1.
So it's 1 over the number of j.
So it's 1.
So just a uniform distribution
across all the tokens
of your vocabulary.
Yeah.
So the question is, how
can I interpret a small--
so the question is, can I
interpret that as a Gaussian?
I think.
So it's kind of tough
because Gaussian,
you have some continuous
quantities in the x-axis.
So here, you have tokens.
So it's kind of discrete.
And it's not something
that you can order.
So I just probably interpret
that as small temperature
is very spiky.
So you will really have
a given set of tokens
that are the highest probable
that will appear more.
And if you have a
high temperature,
then basically,
tokens, even the ones
that were not there to
be the highest probable,
will actually have an adjusted
probability that will be higher.
Yes.
So you can think of it as some
kind of scaling in that sense.
So long story short,
what I want to tell
you is if you have
a small temperature,
it will encourage the next
token to be geared towards being
the highest probable token.
And then if you have
a high temperature,
I guess the distribution
of probabilities
will be kind of
closer to a uniform
if you're really increase
that temperature by a lot.
So your output will
be more creative.
You will have tokens
that you would have not
drawn that would be drawn.
And so what that means
in practice, if you're
with your favorite LLM.
And let's suppose you
want to, I don't know,
write something very creative.
So which one would you use?
Would you use a low temperature
or high temperature?
High temperature?
Yes.
So if you want something that
is more deterministic, more,
I guess, closer to something
that is very, I guess,
what you think would be
high quality, will use
more of a lower temperature.
So one note here is that if
you have a strictly positive
temperature, every time you
run your model over an input,
you will obtain a
different output.
So something I want to point out
is nothing in the transformer
architecture is probabilistic.
Everything is deterministic.
The only thing that
is not deterministic
is how you sample
the next token.
It's the only thing that
is not deterministic.
So what will you do to have
a deterministic output?
You have t equal to 0.
T equal to 0, you know
for sure that your output
will be just one thing
and nothing else.
Well, that's what it's
the theoretical property.
But in practice,
you have some stuff
that is happening in
the computation that
introduces some
non-deterministic operations.
It's much more advanced than
the scope of this class,
much more advanced of
the scope of this class.
I just want to call out that
in practice, t equal to 0,
may lead to different
results because of this kind
of practical piece.
So what I recommend.
So there's a suggested
reading in case
you're completely optional.
So there is a very
recent article
around defeating
non-determinism in LM inference.
So I recommend that you read
it in case you're interested.
So the high level idea is
our GPUs, our hardware,
when they reduce some
of these operations,
sometimes they are
reducing numbers that
are on really different scales.
So the order at which these
operations are happening
is actually quite important.
So the idea is if
these operations
they happen in
different order, it
may lead to different results.
Even if in theory, it
should be exactly the same,
in practice, it may
not be the same.
And this article
actually does a great job
at just explaining
the intuition.
So yeah, just if you're
interested, completely optional.
Cool.
I know I'm kind of
late, so I guess,
last thing that I want
to say is let's suppose,
what you want to do is to
generate an output in a very
specific format.
Let's suppose a JSON format.
So I guess, a very
naive approach
would be to tell your LLM, well,
please generate this in JSON.
And then it produces something.
And then you try to see
if it's a valid JSON.
If it's not, you repeat--
you just tell it
to generate again
until it does something well.
So that's the first
naive approach.
Well, there is a second approach
that is called guided decoding.
And what that does is during
the generation process,
it filters out what it
calls invalid next tokens.
So here, let's suppose I
want to generate this JSON.
I know for sure that
my first token must
be something that opens the--
I forgot what the English
word was for this,
but it just opens the brackets.
Yeah.
Open the brackets.
So you can only have
this and then you
can only have the property
name and so on and so forth.
And sometimes you can have more
than one permitted next token,
in which case you would go back
to our next token strategy.
Yeah.
So the question is, how do
you restrict the other tokens?
So there's a bunch of
papers that go into that.
We will not cover this.
But I can give
you some pointers.
Just type finite state
machine FSM context grammar.
So there's a bunch of
papers that do that.
We will not cover that here.
Cool.
And I think with that, we
will go to the second part
with Shervin.
Great.
Thank you, Afshin.
So now, together,
we're going to look
at different
prompting strategies.
So now that how
responses are generated,
we're going to see
how to get responses
and how to get great responses.
So let's go back to
our favorite example
about our cute teddy bear.
So just I want to introduce
one piece of vocabulary.
So when you have
some kind of input,
you have the length
of your inputs
measured in number of tokens.
And you will see
in the literature
that it can have
different names.
So you can see it called
context length, context size ,
window size.
And I think the
latest tools if you
code on Cursor or any
other code-assisted tool,
I think they call it
more context length,
but all these terms
are equivalent
and denote the same thing.
OK.
So now I want to take some
time to discuss what can be
some orders of magnitude here.
So like modern day
LLMs, they tend
to be in the order of
magnitude of tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands or
millions of input tokens
as inputs.
So this is the kind
of input it can take.
So sometimes, you hear some
new LLM boosts some number.
And then that number of
context length is exactly that.
So it's how much tokens can it
accommodate in a single pass.
OK.
Great.
And then yeah, the
models, you have
seen maybe some advertisement
of these models.
So I think at Gemini
and others that
are in the million territory.
Does that mean it's
all nice and pretty?
If we have more context length,
is it going to solve everything?
Actually not.
There is a phenomenon
that was recently
dubbed as context rot in a paper
from earlier this summer, where
basically, the authors
are experimenting
the capacity of the
model to retrieve
some piece of information
in a test called needle
in a Haystack.
So basically, they
ask some question.
And in larger and larger pieces
of text, they bury the answer.
And they try to look at
the capacity of the model
to surface that answer.
And then you can see that with
respect to an increasing context
length, that ability to
ground the information
with the answer that is
in the context decreases.
And the paper I think is
a very interesting one.
It controls with respect to
what else is in the context.
There is a term of distractors,
where they put some noise
and then they see
distractors basically
contribute in decreasing
the retrieval capability.
So also, what is in
your context matters.
So this is why in general,
when you have a retrieval
problem, where you want to
use your LLM to solve it,
you have some good
incentive to try
to target as much as possible,
the right piece of context
for your LLM to
see and predict on.
OK.
Great.
Yep.
Yeah.
So the question is, is the
context length exactly what
is shown during self-attention?
Yes.
Yeah.
And then we're
going to see-- so I
think we saw last time
that sometimes there
are some tricks that are
used for the complexity
of the self-attention
mechanism not to be n squared.
So this is what is being
used to manage basically
the complexity of
the computations
as the context length grows.
Yeah.
But great call out to that.
That's exactly what is it about.
OK.
Great.
Any questions?
Any other questions?
OK.
Great.
So now, let's define what do
prompts usually look like.
So there is no formal theory on
how to structure a given prompt.
But these are the main
lines that are usually found
in prompts presented to models.
So you can distinguish
a part that
is setting up the context where
you just put the setting, you
make it clear to the model, what
kind of query you want to issue.
Then let's say, if you
have some tasks that you
want the model to perform,
you have instructions.
And then these instructions
are some of them function
that take as input something.
So you add some inputs.
And in order to get
what you want out
of the model's response, you may
want to add some constraints out
of it.
So here, we took our favorite
example with a teddy bear.
The context is what
is the teddy bear--
basically, what is the
mood of the teddy bear?
What do we want to do in order
to make our teddy bear happy?
And then we give
some input regarding
where the story that
we want to generate is.
And then we give
some constraints.
If you want some other
example in the LLMs
that you query every day, so the
context could be some sentence
that says, you are ChatGPT.
We are October 10.
It is 4:44 PM.
So you set the setup.
The instructions
can be basically
what the user queries
alongside the inputs.
And then constraints
might be things
that you don't see
as a user, but that
might be present in the prompts
given to the LLM, such as safety
instructions.
For example, do not generate
any contents that might lead
to harm, or things like this.
So every time you see an
input being fed to an LLM,
I think these projections,
these four dimensions
can be a good mental model of
seeing which pieces correspond
to what goal in that structure.
Does that make sense?
OK, great.
So now that we know
what kind of mindsets
we might have for
inputs to an LLM,
let's see how we can get
an LLM to do what we want.
And let's see how we can get
an LLM to do what we want
without tuning any weights.
And we can do so with a concept
called in-context learning,
where the learning is a bit
of a term that is overloaded
because you don't
actually learn anything
with respect to the
weights of the LLM,
but you can distill some
knowledge inside of it
as part of the context in
order to do what you want.
So you distinguish
two main categories
of in-context learning.
So there is one category
that is very simple.
In mindset, it's
called zero-shot.
It's basically you don't give
anything other than your input,
your input query.
You just ask the LLM to
do what you want to do.
And then there is
another school of thought
called few-shot
learning, where you
give examples of inputs
and outputs to the LLM
before asking the input
that you're interested in.
So in the case of a teddy
bears and a bedtime stories, so
you might name your teddy bears.
So maybe you have teddy
bear that's called Teddy.
And you generated a story.
So you put your query,
you put the story
that you want to generate, and
you give multiple such examples.
And let's say you have another
teddy bear that's called Bob.
And then you want to
generate a story for Bob.
So you put all of
these examples,
and you ask the LLM
to generate the story
that you're interested in.
And then this is basically what
we call a few-shots setting.
OK.
Great.
So now, generally, when
you look at the performance
of the resulting
task, giving examples
tends to steer the LLM
nicely into the task
that you're interested in.
Just because you
have given an idea
to the model of what
you are looking for.
And then it can use what it
has learned during its training
process to connect the dots
and basically replicates.
But of course, you need
to gather such examples.
So this is costly.
This will put some more
tokens in the context window.
So you will need
to more compute.
But there is an
interesting trade
off here that we see
in recent models.
So they are gaining more and
more reasoning capabilities,
which is why I put the
generally nuance in italic here.
So they are generally better,
few-shots, but not always.
Because these days, with
these better models,
people have seen that with
basically making the instruction
better, you could
make the performance
of in-context learning on
par, or even better than
if you provide examples, because
basically, when you think of it,
when you provide examples,
you constrain your model
into given sets of
examples that are finite.
So when you are
at inference time,
let's say, you want to perform
a task on a distribution of data
that has not been seen,
it is harder for the model
to generalize because it
will try to align on what
it has seen in the context.
Whereas if you turn your
instructions into something that
is more reasoning
based, you explain
how to do the task
with natural language,
it can use its reasoning
abilities to actually do it.
And this is something that you
see more and more these days.
So the literature on this, I
think, is still in progress,
but you have some
papers like a plan
and solve that's I
think came out recently.
And that shows if you ask the
LLM to plan itself and then
solve something, it can
have very good performance.
So yeah, this is an
interesting fact.
OK.
Great.
So now that we have seen
basically the kinds of learning
that we have, now,
we're going to see
what we can do to improve
the quality of the response.
So there is this concept
called chain of thought,
where researchers have seen that
if you force the model to come
up with some rationale
to some answer
before actually giving it, it
would give higher performance.
So this is what people
call as chain of thought.
It's basically what
led you to the answer.
So here, for example,
if you ask yourself,
how old is this teddy bear?
And if you force the model to
respond directly with a number,
it might not be able
to do the connection as
to exactly why the Teddy
bear is a given age.
Whereas when you give the
full chain of reasoning,
then it becomes clear as to
what led to that response.
So I think this is the main
mindset behind this technique.
And basically, this
is something that can
be used in in-context learning.
So if you give few-shot
examples, how old was this Teddy
bear, you give some
number and then
you slightly change the query.
And then based on the
reasoning, formatting, and then
the response, the LLM can adjust
the reasoning and the response
accordingly.
And it will force the model
to output some reasoning
alongside the response,
which shows an improvement
in basically metrics.
OK, great.
And then yeah, something
else that I want to say,
let's say, you want to do a
task and you want to do it well.
m you will always have some
samples that do not work.
And then for them, you want
to have debugging ability.
And usually when
you debug with LLMs,
you don't debug
like the old days.
You don't look at weights at
the intrinsics of the LLM.
What you want is something
more interpretable
that comes out of it
in terms of tokens.
And usually, with
these techniques,
you can see the reasoning
that the model had before
outputting a given response.
And you can debug
basically what went wrong.
So if you ask how old will
the bear be next year.
And if in the chain of thought
it says, hey, we're in 2019,
you know that somehow
in your context,
oh, maybe I put the
wrong dates in there.
So you can trace back to--
you can do some root
causing very easily.
So it's also used for that.
And, exactly, in the same
way as other techniques
that increase the
number of tokens,
this is a trade off
that you have to manage,
that it will, of course, take
more time to infer because you
need to generate more tokens.
But typically,
we're fine with it.
Any questions on COT?
OK, great.
So now let's take
it one step further.
So I want to introduce even
to make COT even stronger,
you can sample your model.
Several times,
look at the answers
it generates, and then do
some majority voting to select
the answer that was
predicted most of the times
by a given LLM.
And this is what we
call self-consistency,
where basically, you sample
responses multiple times
and then parse
the actual answer.
So basically, you factor
out the whole reasoning
and then try to
target the answer.
And then by majority
voting, you can come up
to an answer in a
more robust way.
Yep.
So the question is, do you
need to have some benchmark
to know if it's better?
And yes, absolutely.
I think the paper operates
on top of all the arithmetic
and then mathematical
based ones.
And I think one tangential
question to yours
is how can you locate
the answer and then do
measure majority voting on it.
So typically, you can
put into the context
some instruction that says,
put the actual answer last.
So you can just
extract the last.
People, I think, use regex
based techniques, otherwise,
to extract the answer.
Or you could even think
of using some other LLM
to extract the answer.
So there is always
a way to do it.
But yeah, to your point,
yes, we need some benchmark
and then ground truth
labels to assert
that this is indeed better.
Yeah.
So the request here--
so the question is,
is it going to be sent to
the same request as example?
So typically, you
sample it in parallel.
So basically, you ask your
model exactly what Afshin just
mentioned.
You sample from the
probability distribution of BOS
and whatever tokens you
had, the next token.
And you do that in several
other kind of branches.
And you do that, all
of that, in parallel.
And then you parse the
answer at the end of it.
So basically, the
latency of this process
is equal, roughly, to
the maximum latency
of either parallel generation.
Because you can do all
of this in parallel.
So none of these go into
the context of each other.
They're all done in parallel.
And then you get
the final answer.
OK, great.
All good?
So now that we have seen a
few prompting techniques,
I want to cover together
tricks that people have come up
with at inference time
to make the generation as
efficient as possible.
And basically, yeah, so
in modern day models,
you have a lot of parameters.
You want to generate
a lot of tokens.
How do you do it the most
efficiently possible?
So I want us to divide this
thought process into two parts.
So we're going to see what
methods we can come up with that
give us increased efficiency
on an exact level.
So you exactly do
the same computations
as you were supposed to do,
but in a more efficient way.
And I put some hints as
to what kind of techniques
we're going to explore.
So let's try to
look for techniques
that avoid redundancies.
Let's try to see what
we could do to manage
the memory in the best way.
And also, let's try to
see if we can reformulate
the equations inside the LLM
in a way that could simplify
the generation in practice.
Then there is a second
category that we're
going to explore as well.
That is going to focus on
what kind of approximations
it might be fine to do,
and get a high quality
answer at a lesser cost,
but to be approximate.
So we have what kind
of variations we
could do on the architecture?
Is there something we
could do on the embeddings
to make them more efficient?
And then maybe on the
token prediction side,
is there something we
could do to make it faster?
Does that sound good?
So we have approximately
22 minutes.
We're going to try to go
through all of them here.
OK.
So I grouped the
categories of techniques
into exact and
approximate techniques.
But actually,
we're going to look
at them in a grouped manner.
First, looking at
the attention layer,
seeing what kind of techniques
we could have there.
And then in a second
part, we're going
to look at the output layer.
And then see what we can do at
the level of token generation
to make things as
good as possible.
So let's start at
the attention level.
So we have seen that
for every token,
you need the current token to
attend to the previous ones
in this masked self-attention.
So let's say you
generate your sequence.
You are at a given token.
So let's say, you have
generated a cute teddy bear.
And then now you are at ease.
Now you have the query ease.
You will compute the key
representation and the value
representation of ease.
Because of course,
you have to do it.
It's your current token.
But we want to have a way to
reuse the past computations we
had done to compute
the key representation
of the previous tokens and
the value representation
of the previous tokens.
Does that make sense as a goal?
Does everyone agree?
OK.
And more precisely,
basically, we
want to find a way for the key
and value matrices to be saved.
And I'm not
underlining the Q part
here because of course,
the query corresponding
to the previous
tokens are not going
to be of interest for
the present token.
So it's like the
key and value part.
OK.
So there is this concept
of KV cache, where
the goal is to store
this key and value
matrices somewhere, and reuse
them directly from the cache.
So what I just
mentioned here, when
you want to compute
a given token,
you would reuse the
key and the value
directly from the cache
instead of computing it again.
So this is basically,
representation of what
we just mentioned here.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Awesome.
So what else could we do?
Yeah.
Great question.
So during training,
do we do KV caching?
I would say during training,
you have this concept
of teacher forcing, where
you put all your inputs
and pass it all
together at once.
So this concept of KV
caching doesn't even come up.
Yeah.
But great one.
Yep.
Yeah so the question was,
what is the point of all this?
We want to just reuse
the computations that
were already done.
And then your answer is yes.
Spot on.
Any other questions?
OK, great.
So now that we have seen that
we could cache these quantities.
So what else could we do?
So is there something
from last week's lecture
that we could reuse,
maybe something
that reduces the amount of
cache, the key and value?
Do we have some techniques?
Sparse attention.
Yeah, that could be.
That could be, but not here.
Let's say you're
attending to everyone
and you focus on the
number of keys and values.
Is there a way to
reduce this number?
So just to recap,
we have here, I'm
operating in the context of
multi-head attention, which
is you have your h heads.
So you have h number
of query projections,
h key projections,
h value projections.
These are any technique
from last week
that we could reuse that
could reduce this number.
Yeah.
I heard it.
Group query attention.
Yeah, exactly.
So we had these concept of
grouping keys and values
together, where basically the
general formulation is called
group query attention, where
you group these, and then
the external values h and
1 denotes respectively
the full multi-head attention,
and then multi query attention.
And then in modern day
LLMs, a lot of papers,
they use GQA, with some
group that is sensible value.
So this is also
something we can do.
OK, great.
And now I'm going to go a
little bit into the hardware
side of things.
So if we were to store the cache
for all these values in a naive
way, at inference time.
So let's say you receive--
so let's say I'm an
inference server,
I receive queries
from multiple users.
And let's say I receive a query
one and I receive a query two,
a naive way of storing the
key and value matrices would
be in reserving a
portion of the memory
at the beginning that correspond
to the entire context length,
because you don't where
you're going to stop.
You're decoding because
you stop your decoding
when you hit the EOS token.
So you would have
this whole block
of size context
length, maximum context
length that could be reserved.
So one observation is that
it leads to a lot of waste.
So let's say if your context
length is of size like 2k,
you have 2k reserved for
a given request 2k there.
So at any given time, let's say,
you want to get more requests,
you want to serve more requests.
Your memory will
very quickly not
have enough space
to accommodate Does
these constraints or this
challenge make sense?
Yeah.
OK.
And then there is this paper
that is called PagedAttention.
And it defines
several quantities.
So there is this reserved
quantity internal fragmentation
and external fragmentation.
Internal fragmentation
is basically
the space that is being
reserved by the model
to complete the request.
And the reserved spot
is the subset of it
that corresponds to tokens
that were actually being used.
So it's the kind of
space that's actually
used internal fragmentation.
There is nothing in there,
but it was reserved.
And external fragmentation is
the memory management system
that doesn't necessarily put
one block one after another,
but has its own way of
allocating memory blocks.
So it might leave
some other gaps.
And they came up
with a system that
is called a PagedAttention
that is powering
one inference package
called the vLLM that
solves this issue by mapping,
like the generation process
by blocks of fixed size.
So instead of allocating a
whole portion of the memory
to answer a given
request, it breaks it down
by smaller chunks.
So I think the paper takes
like a value of 16 for blocks.
So as you can see, let's say
you are in a generation process
and you have used
a given row, you
would just start using
another row without wasting
more space than that.
And then you have
some dictionary
that maps token position indices
to basically their cache values.
So there is a smart
way of managing it.
And they show that it reduces
fragmentation by quite a lot.
Yeah.
OK, great.
Now let's do something
else with this KV cache.
So we just saw that you have
your internal representation
of your token and you project
it into query, key, and value.
And then key and
value is actually
something that is of a dimension
that is like non-negligible.
And you need to store
each copies of it
in each transformer block.
So you have many
of these vectors
that you need to keep track of.
And is there a way to make that
representation somehow more
compact?
And this is a topic
that DeepSeek has tried
to tackle in a concept called--
I think it was called
multi-latent attention.
We're going to see--
so let's look at
the vanilla case.
If you are in
multi-head attention,
then for a given
representation of a token,
you have h projection matrices
that turn it into a key.
Does everyone agree with that?
So the kind of
self-attention formula,
you have a projection
matrix wk for keys,
that will project the token
representation into some key.
And you have h heads.
You have h such
projections and you
have h such resulting
embeddings that you
need to store in your cache.
Because you have that for
keys, you have that for values.
That's a lot of
vectors to store.
And these keys and values,
they are quite long as well.
So let's see if we
can make it smaller.
What multi-latent
attention does is
that it factorizes
these projection matrix
into an intermediary
space that is
of lower dimension
than the space of keys.
You have a first
transformation that
reduces the dimension
and then another one that
decompresses it.
So this is the first
operation that they
did in order to make the
representation more compact.
But they did something
else that is very smart.
They said that the
compression matrix
could be shared across
keys and values, which
says for a given token
representation, the cache
that you need to store for keys
and for values is the same.
And then you would have
still different matrices
here for the decompression
part to actually learn
different representations
for a key and value.
But one simplification
here has been to share it
for across keys and values.
And even better, share
it across the h heads.
So instead of having h such
embeddings, you have just one.
And then you do that for key.
You do that for value.
So at the end of it, for
every transformer block,
you have a single
representation per token.
Does that make sense?
So not only you have
less things to store.
The DeepSeek V2 paper also
showed a performance improvement
that it's kind of credited
some regularization
consequence of doing so.
So it learns representations
that are maybe more useful
and shared across
keys and values.
So apparently there is also
performance benefits to it that
is not just hardware based.
OK, great.
So now we have seen some--
Yeah.
So the question is, do you
tune the low rank dimension?
So the dimension itself
is a design choice.
It's fixed.
So the question is,
is it the same lower
dimension for everyone.
So the dimension size is fixed
and is the same for everyone.
I think.
But it's a design choice.
You could have different ones,
but I think in practice it
might be the same one.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
OK, great.
So now we have less
than 10 minutes.
We are going to cover techniques
that operate at the output
token level.
And then start with a concept
called speculative decoding.
That is a very
interesting method
that uses some smaller model to
help the generation of a bigger
model, and then uses
some scheme that
makes the distribution outputs
match one of the target one.
So it uses a
combination of tricks
of using a smaller model to
generate things, and then
gates it with some
mathematical based properties
to ensure we get a
distribution that
looks the one of the big model.
So here's what is the
lectures, the mindset of it.
So let's just come back
to our favorite example
about teddy bears.
So what you do is
that you ask a smaller
model, that the paper calls
draft, to generate next words.
So you have my teddy bear.
What could be next words?
So you have one pass.
You find token is.
You fit token is here again.
You find cute and smart.
Since the LLM is small, this
is typically done faster than
with the big LLM.
And then once you
have all of these,
you put the tokens that are
predicted by the smaller LLM
all as inputs to
the target's LLM.
That is like the bigger
model, like the one
that you use, to
generate probability
distributions for each of them.
And then we're going
to see that by having
some rule on the output
distribution of each
of these tokens, you can
simulate a probability
distribution of each token
of each next token that
looks one of the target models.
So here's basically how it goes.
So it looks at the
probability of the token
that the draft
model has predicted.
So if the probability
of the draft model
is bigger than the one of the
draft model in the draft model's
output distribution, then
you just accept the token.
Otherwise, you have some
acceptance rejection mechanism
that either accepts the
token or rejects it.
And let's say
everything is accepted.
Then in a single pass,
you are able to advance
by way more tokens.
And then if it fails,
then basically you
resume the process of generation
from that good token onwards
with some adjustments
on the distribution.
So one question that you
might ask from all of this,
this looks like a recipe.
Why is that matching
the target distribution?
So if you start from the
law of total probability
and write each term
with these quantities.
Then you will find the target
distribution at the end.
So it's an exercise that
I encourage you to do.
And the paper that is
attached to the slide
here demonstrates it
in just a few lines.
So it's a very simple proof.
And I think it's a very,
very interesting one.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
The question is, is
that rejection sampling?
Yeah.
So some of you might be
familiar with it already.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
And then one thing that
I didn't say is that
why did we even put
the last token here?
We put all the draft
tokens, but also
the last one that
was predicted because
by doing a single forward pass
with all these draft tokens,
you get for free the probability
distribution of the token
that comes after that you can
then just sample from Qk plus 1.
So just to give some
summary of the rationale.
Doing a single pass is
as expensive as doing
one pass at a time,
because at inference time,
you're memory bounds back.
In other words, computations
are not the limiting factor.
It's basically the
memory that will
bottleneck your computation.
So you want to do it
on a smaller model.
And then on the
big model, you want
to compute all of these
probability distributions
at once.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Great.
And then I want to talk
about one last technique
that is called
multi-token prediction.
It's the same-- so by the
way, this previous technique
was called speculative decoding.
And then this one is
basically doing the same.
So it's doing slightly
a different thing.
But the draft model is
embedded in the same model,
which is very powerful.
So basically, it's a model
that attaches multiple heads
on top of the representation
of the last decoder.
And the process here is
that at training time,
it doesn't do next
word prediction.
It does multi word prediction.
And at test time, the draft
model is all your heads.
And your main model is
just the first head.
So you have all
your draft tokens
that you then feed
back to the first head
and then do
acceptance rejection.
So the paper does
it in a greedy way.
So it doesn't do it
with this formula.
Because since the architecture
and then the objective function
has changed, you don't have this
nice property of finding again,
the next token
predictions distribution.
But you have a slight
variation of it.
And yeah.
So like the interesting
notes out of the multi
token prediction is the
change in objective function.
And then second, the fact that
the draft model and the target
model are basically
embedded in the same one.
So don't have to
separate the two.
And yeah.
So you do remember this slide?
We have explored
techniques that can
remedy each of these aspects.
So yeah.
I highly recommend taking a
look at the associated papers
as well.
And with that,
thank you very much.